these are workers from an energy company
calling at the home of a customer who
owed money their aim was to get in and
force the installation of a prepayment
meter after a few minutes they started
to drill through the door
[Music]
the owner of the house in Birmingham was
at work at the time she agreed to speak
to us but wanted us to protect her
identity it felt as though I'd been
burgled I felt unsafe it just didn't
make any sense to me as to why they
needed to take that action I was
corresponding with them
the same thing happened to this family
when they were out workers went in to
their flat in London I literally had a
panic attack the neighbors actually came
downstairs and they actually came in
they heard me crying they heard me being
upset my mom didn't know what was going
on she's 90 years old so she just saw me
wandering around the flat hysterical
once the meters are in if the money runs
out so does the power supply
this undercover filming caused outrage
it led to calls for the practice to be
banned altogether and Charities say the
new rules that only restrict forced
installations don't protect enough
people
well they've obviously picked 85 Plus
because it's the smallest group and they
want to maximize the number of people
that they can impose prepayment meters
on
um so
yes it's great that those few people are
protected but that's a tiny tip of the
iceberg of the size of the issue and
really a complete distraction
the chief executive of off gems said it
must be as a last resort and customers
in vulnerable situations will be given
the extra care and consideration they
deserve over and above the rules already
in place by suppliers something that is
clearly not always been happening but by
stopping short of a ban more families
will find their homes are targeted if
they fall behind on their bills Becky
Johnson Sky News Birmingham